what's up y'all usually I don't do
controls to the episodes but then I
remember I had a bunch of turday and we
need people there this is a business
September 14th
I'm in Camden New Jersey with Miss
Lauren Hill if not I'll be in Bristol
Virginia with Miss Lauren Hill or not
and I'll be in Wilmington Delaware and
it'd be me these head Tony trim and who
knows who else
Lauren Hill and I will be there there's
a bunch of other dates Miami San Diego
LA Bay Area C Atta Columbia Missouri
check them all out at Hannibal Burress
dot-com share the episodes in Harlem to
whatever you know check out follow Tony
shrim at Tony trim I was that ad lib
excited you today's episode with Leon
Rogers outstanding comedian from Chicago
who I came up watching and studying when
I was you know leaves running a lot of
great rooms in Chicago and was always
coming through fresh material so he was
great to watch an outstanding comedian
and currently on WGCI
6:00 a.m. to 10:00 a.m. 1:07 5:00 Monday
through Friday I've been through there
before as a guest and it's a tough trip
to make man is early downtown Chicago
that early whoo
anyway this was fun up we talk you know
old-school Chicago comedy tell us some
stories about Bernie Mac his d-day
career a little bit auto
with a parent so flying lotus drop that
beat man I'm about to give five D what
if I had a if we had a program director
for this they would say you need to lay
off the out of school
welcome to their hands and rambling
podcast
I'm your host handlebars over there on
the drums
Tony trim with our special guest from
the shine on every morning 1:07 5w g zi
Leon Rogers what all that what's
happening man get up off Anita food
don't what's happening man I can't call
it man happy to be alive beautiful
loving life right now in a good place
man you know sometimes and our
profession in what we do sometimes you
get look that up and stuff I'm actually
in a good place right now I can't
complain it's been a good stretch good
man you know I was worried not worried
but you you on every morning at six to
ten yep and this is eleven is now I was
one I was like you know with this the
first thing I'm doing Yoli no don't come
in sharp and fired a madman listen good
radio there I tell all comments that
want to do radios you don't have the
thirty minutes to screw off cubicle time
yeah you know you work a regular job you
can warm up in the break room for thirty
minutes
picking up no box again we gonna get
about 944 yeah I job
swoons like on we are sick I don't feel
good you know it's bright lights big
city because people ride to work on
those people time their data us yeah if
I sound like crap on it they might punch
out or they don't want to tune in so
they want to hear me trippin so you know
rain sleet of snow you got go the show
starts at 6:00 a.m. at 6:00 but we do
know how to get a ride that's gonna say
you got a say you're waking up at like
3:00 in the morning I leave out my house
about 3:45
let's care you want these teams you
don't even have a nightlight you know go
out I do those like they're crazy that's
clearly not y'all celebrities get on
cocaine it's not even bother to stay
awake he goes to the comedy show tonight
and and [ __ ] I'll get home I'll lay down
about 12:30 1:00 my alarm is off about
3:15 3:20 wakes up at 3:15 I get up does
a bunch of cocaine I pick it out
so not now the cool thing is though so
like when I leave you guys I got a
little thing to do
like for MetroPCS shoutout to MetroPCS
and then I'm done to the comedy show
later on tonight
yeah thirty nine o'clock so I'll
probably sleep catch catnap you know due
to over 40 napping Jesus but you were my
kids don't like literally I have to say
leave me the [ __ ] alone go away tell my
for yo that media scram you there's
nothing in your day that matches up with
mine
somebody put that coat on your hook [ __ ]
idea yes Gaza massive oh that's crazy
looking for 15 years he been already 14
years why all that because you were on
power 92 years and then I crossed over
and went to went from you know went from
went to d1 school you know I don't know
if we talked about this
oh you but it was the funniest thing
when chance the rapper made the angels
track
and they on the his version of the
original Verdi says GCI 107 my 9250 our
107 pining for shock power 92 baby -
hatred aren't you and so I listened to
it like that abundant and then I happen
to be listening to one of the stations
in the car or you happen to be on an
uber something and I was like getting
high for that part and it was this 107
107 5 107 but they ended up with 92.3
partied up every oh it's real it's real
it's like dominoes and pizza like it's
real if it was come on honor like I know
you didn't do it right
holiday hours and you're like the thing
about that is though like I have a lot
of friends that still work oh sure and
I'm not never been one to do the whole
I'm on this station so let me take shots
at them and even though I've had some of
my quote/unquote friends that work over
there take shot cuz I'm gonna do shot at
the day these are jobs right and when
that when when you get called in that
office that day because it's going to
happen and they say hey you know thanks
been good run but we're gonna put this
19 year old kid in your spot right now
yeah then what you know I'm saying like
I'm gonna burn them busy I'm not gonna
forsake people that I care about as a
human being for the sake of coz I wear
the colors of the station I do I
represent my station everywhere I go
absolutely you know WG I always they
wouldn't know wouldn't number one
station with a bigger station with a
heritage station but I think that I mean
I don't respect
shag I don't mean I respect Ferris was a
good friend of mine you know JL and the
people that work over on the other side
but it is what it is it is Angie's yeah
you know stronger reception when you get
further minute you go to be Walter
listen us 92 it starts getting fuzzy you
get out
I got like a mom and pops organism one
guy Crawford broadcasting was you know
you know I heart media loans WGCI they
also own you know what a breakfast club
broadcast you know kids out of New York
you know so you got power in LA yeah
we're big boy on the station so I mean
like I said it's like Northern Illinois
and Michigan football yeah okay well
yeah d1 but so yeah I heart it's part of
that's a machine where if the where you
know they have the artist that they like
they're gonna have some push through
absolutely yeah absolutely so I mean but
acting today it's a job it's a job man
and something I enjoy doing a lot of
people can't say that you enjoyed
getting up and going to work every day I
do I actually love it you know Santa's
had 30 45 and I listen I don't even
imagine that lifestyle tell me only time
I regret it is like so say like um
Thursday nights I do this thing at
Chili's where we do old-school hip-hop
yeah and I spend a lot of times I'm the
last DJ yeah so I we get out of there
like 1:30 Oh - so I just stay up yeah go
to sleep if I go to sleep is right right
but I make sure that Friday I don't have
nothing planned for when I get off work
so that way I can come home and not out
forget about so you just doing the
graveyard shift 5 to 6 hours a day
I might get 5 see nobody my age I
probably should be getting 8 to 10 but
it used to you because I was looking at
your schedule doing my research I'm a
professional
I saw you hosting an album release party
tomorrow
they're leaving there and doing a comedy
show out and Harvey they're leaving
they're go doing the DJ thing and
you know just stay up go to work and get
off sleep half of Friday away then
probably around about 8:30 9 o'clock get
up and so you drink a lot of coffee or
you're on the adderall know what I mean
are you just mad you know my guilty
pleasure is broke and I got to stop
because it's not good for me
kickstart yeah now a new case time and I
have to catch myself I used to be like
three or four toes joints a day way
what's kickstart Mountain Dew kickstart
they're like the editor yeah but it's
like they got some very exquisite
flavors oh the pineapple mango and the
raspberry citrus are users all [ __ ]
energy I used to pop them like 3/4 day
and I just was feeling like [ __ ] like
and I'll go
you know man my doctor is like hey man
we're getting some rest on Sonya about
five or six days a week
I say we say well what do you do to stay
up I said what drink no energy and he's
like stop that like you know cool so now
I'm down to like one I curb myself to
like one and I just drink a lot of water
but I mean like I said I see how a
somebody who have to remember scripts or
someone's got a busy schedule will do a
line of blow and knock it out cuz you
get it yeah I just kept putting that in
my nose like okay yeah that's fine away
you go I put it underneath the tongue or
somewhere maybe I get a couple things
cleaned up but then they do the read the
line reading let's take it one more time
but a little bit slower he'll it down a
little bit as it's film you know as you
do that in post-production
it's slower got in post-production Dan
to it all the [ __ ] time where's my
sandwich and if you did it to your mouth
you you make it come on yeah so I'm
getting a raise then yeah but I do see
how celebrities probably do cocaine and
just like just to stay up because I
can't do coffee I'm not a coffee guy
never had coffee in my life it looks
disgusting
my mother drinks her coffee like
straight black like I'm like your crate
that looks like you drink it oil
coffee different people that want to
[ __ ] in the morning right
really that's it I didn't like your [ __ ]
right away well I got an aunty some
cooking you can eat better get that done
yeah real quick
she just got consistent if she
consistent diarrhea food we banned her
from a green bean casserole at
Thanksgiving Day oh I'm not gonna hear
this oh I'm a Saturday I Dora because
he's not gonna go is not in this loop
she's like 60 Plus that's the worst like
I we should think she was cooking in
like unclean dishes cuz everything she
could how many years did it take before
y'all said y'all daughter my mother was
my dad's sister rest in peace he was
just like after about two or three times
he's like a chill on that well you all
need you to bring enough to do it bring
yourself oh that hurt women foot
especially older women put a lot of
pride into the cooking so sheets you
know so like a dessert so don't know
what it is is like you just be like it
disengages
evisceration bowels it's instant like
with your not our yeah oh man yeah and
you know yeah I crave only got two
bathrooms so once - I'm tied up like the
kids like well what happened we ate some
outdoors red velvet cake with a diary
stuff that make yo boughs explode
[Music]
Beccaria with diarrhea
[Music]
yeah
Hershey's course Hershey squirts
Hershey's please make it hurt the box
okay Campbell clouds make it : cleans :
cleans didn't want : clean yo I remember
I forgot that [ __ ] is amazing I just
want to get whiter be at the crib I
don't know where my DJ said just by
screaming out over the mic last call I
remove recent holiday I know if it was
Thanksgiving a Christmas out in my
sister's house in Phoenix and I had some
it was mine I just had to keep going to
the bathroom it was it was a I can't
believe whatever I ate this diarrhea is
taking time away from my family
yeah okay I can't spend time with my
family I hated I'm [ __ ] my best
rating while we're on the topic I
shouldn't like at my job like you know
like I kind of like you have to go under
the stars our bathrooms are wonderful I
had me as a [ __ ] beautiful well-kept
maintained soft ambient light yes we're
gonna be people are irritable early in
the morning imagine if you saw a dirty
bathroom at 6:45 you heard a freak out
who's being like you know I like this
imagine the light it's really light or
cheats on it's just light enough for you
to read a magazine but not over-bright
you know I'm saying but once I'm happy
even my life don't get in the stall like
right next to me yeah if you're if
you're a runner or like you know that
[ __ ] disturbs me because I'm here
concentrating I'm just you know I'm
doing I'm doing the slow I'm doing the
Tastee Freez cone you know I mean it's
it's a steady
you're saying you know yeah a steady
tasty please coming up you're coming to
the next one and you're like you sound
like a full-blown Chevy
you know you brah Bridey it destroys my
Tastee Freez experience because i'm
going to until you scream
I'm building the cone yes vector man
every time you do that you know that I
don't know you remember to move to a
spectrum and it's now oh my gadget no
spectrum you see you [ __ ] a
young I hate y'all how do you eat when
t6 yeah so spectrum and like white
mutagenic tune in next week for Specter
man I used to call to guy to make him
change overlord request permission to
transformed and they go mission denied
spectrum and your power cells are not
fully charged and then he would just go
back to regular job oh what a monster
[ __ ] up okay so I know everybody
didn't expect imagine get out of one
like yo did it I will will splice it in
thank you good man
this is Overlord every Tiffany's dr.
glorious completed his underground base
in the hawk Pony air yeah we haven't
defined on YouTube I will have to do all
up I got all the episodes at the career
of you know you you follow mo you to to
like salted giant robot gamma all that
is plotted at whole phenomena grew up
watching us but I like the idea of uh
just a practical superhero way like not
you can't right now that you say yeah
boy in straight motion like the monsters
tearing up the city but because he had
fought some other dudes earlier he's not
like fully healed his name was George
with that was the name of his alias he
was George and he worked for this like
environmental company and he would go
outside he's like I can't I can't let
the monster destroy Tokyo overlord
request permission for transformation
permission denied Specter man your power
cells are not at full capacity you are
there
I'm waiting over not yet spec your man
it is too soon after your battle with
glorious creature you need time to
recharge your energy
your mother a request denied I just
stand by another tidal wave watch over
our city Senate yes Precure man that is
it you must wait did he just turn round
that sounds like my type of [ __ ] no I
want to see you soon
and then they will just the rest of
episodes be him in his regular job
actually charged up and then like they
would piss you off because then at the
end they let him transform and then they
show him about to fight the monster but
didn't be like tune in tomorrow to see
him spectrum man beats mega da da da
inspector man top notch cliffhangers
right yeah I'm straight you've never
heard of it the lead villain was a guy
named dr. Gorrie he was a 8 with like
silver hair I used to talk with his hand
he's like I must destroy this is from
the state's not is from Japan man like a
nod okay okay but it showed it on
channel 44 like it came on right before
Voltron and [ __ ] like it used to be that
Voltron and battle of the planets which
was known as g-force yeah there's the
ship Godzilla era yeah all that yeah
yeah like right along in that same genre
good stuff man yo I was looking and I
was looking at this link you post it up
and it pissed me off too whether some
times you see these prank videos where
they what a print is not really a prank
is just some dumb real [ __ ] where's
not really thought out a prank is where
kind of both people can enjoy it but the
but the [ __ ] they be doing these and
[ __ ] somebody be mad about forever
yeah like a prank is the prank is you
know hey up we put a whoopee cushion and
every time Hannibal says the word and
we're going to hit it and make the fart
sound yeah that's a prank
put in a standing next to me in a black
suit and saying I see the target take
the shot
and then when I look down there's a dot
on my chest yeah somebody's playing with
a laser pointer that's a good way to get
killed bro
especially out here like everything
that's going on I was like actions
insane yeah I was walking up to people
he was like yeah I'm standing here such
back has on a black shirt with red logo
take the shot I've been compromised take
the shine in the guy runs away and then
I would look everywhere I was waiting
for one of the people to be like this is
[ __ ]
now I was waiting for somebody a gun and
just start busting whatever they thought
the dot was coming from yeah I know some
of those are fake but some of them is I
seen one was hey we're gonna run up to
people and say what's up and have to use
a cell phone they were gonna run away
with a vote no that's stuff that all
yeah that kick kick in his ass kick
though yeah no I just saw one recently
uh a guy goes into this like pizza place
it's in the hood first of all black guy
runs if he plays and he's yelling at
somebody from behind and behind the
window and then I get out here he's like
no I don't want to get out of here UK
leave me I won't let it go down like
this so he has a gas can
right but the gas can is full of water
but people don't know that he's like but
I don't know what I do without you and
he starts pouring the contents that the
gas can on him like his gas he's about
to let itself on fire
so everybody starts running out people
grab the kids is one guy in the blue
sweatshirt calmly pulls out the biggest
Desert Eagle I've ever seen in my life
and say man toplane I should do is like
no no it's a prank look is one look look
like oh now now when when when man man
but to blow your brains out man man was
like [ __ ] all that give me more pieces
but the kill us over a joke like it I
don't get it bad I don't get the whole I
never got planking I never got none of
that crap like just going and laying
across something I never got you know
none of that stupid [ __ ] I need a prank
involving [ __ ] or piss is not cool I'm
straight on bodily fluids yeah I'm sure
there's no funny way to do that you know
you know use that as show
you've had a bunch of shows around the
city but when I remember specifically
the estate oh yeah it's ready to go
that's what comics came to die
we who come to die salute you because it
was set up like when you come in here at
the stage there are the people here yeah
there's one VIP section over here but
then you had like a balcony yeah people
set up there and it was like the Roman
Colosseum and it would just get so nuts
in the room I would just come up on
stage and be like just kabob because I'm
really fascinated by that old error and
people used to come up and I used to be
like yeah your day is gonna crash and
say yeah and if not if you like you got
boo we just Hollis told him like yeah it
was the energy was amazing I missed that
room Anthony Mason used to be there
heckling my father know where it is to
get heckled by 6:9 NBA player is known
for beating up other big people but one
thing I do like three years in doing one
thing I would say about him rest in
peace man if if you got him with a good
one yeah he would chill cuz he didn't
New York to the heart yeah he like he
try coming he was always a good spirit
dog like in here he will [ __ ] with you
but when you got our said you'd like man
you know just messing with you right but
you'd be like no I'm not sure cuz like
you said 6 9 95 I want no smoke you know
the true story after Dean Mason I should
be this club called voyeur back in the
day and Mase we was out makes was like
how did shots of patron that's when I
should have patron popping but now the
tequila choices Avion tequila please
drink coffee on responsible oh that's
broke
sitting right but um so we as me and
Bianco I'll never forget a couple other
guys my cousin Darryl and uh honey shots
and you knock the back is like
everybody's gonna do to end each your
sin is ten of us everybody won't eat any
solid there's a twist
I watched a study buddy for the whole
plenty knob bro I say it makes doc my
body is not built to doing over
continued shots of anything not even ten
healthy vitamin B shot yeah Songkran
wheatgrass none of that know you will do
your own punching your face yo so I got
down the first five and India I was like
maybe I just started looking at each
other it's kind of throwing him over the
back of the shoulders like I remember
wetting his chick up yeah I thought like
minute we don't God like we're going to
die but to him it was nothing
yeah cuz it yeah he gives he gets drunk
he goes to one of the biggest security
guys in the club let's do six five six
six nice size hey yo Shane you know I
got five grand in my pocket be win
pocket for five grand hey hey hey hey
take it take it
let's go outside and fight like nah
mates now we could nah nah [ __ ] that yo
the money yours when I lose let's go man
he said he talking to the peace a fight
him oh I thought he meant fight just go
fight in general you wanna fight an
abundant he's paying him five grand to
fight him home fire club so my man like
yo y'all junkie number don't look at
them son five g's come on man full so
everybody trying to calm him down right
I chose Judas hang on line man allows
you I tell them right this way sir
and soon as he goes out that side
door I did the a cave his head in with a
barstool or just hold the door yeah he
locked out he's like no sergeant nice
cool man you know give him his money
back I said I'm not touching that you
got the money and I said cool because
you don't come looking for it right to
me and I don't want to be the one that
has it so he got his money back he's
like you know [ __ ] oh they all pushing
me five g's where the lose ain't nobody
will nothing because I own some savage
in White City go ahead I'm like yo man
yo you gotta calm down man you can't go
to a club and just challenge the
security also it wasn't because of the
Brooklyn Park okay you're a huge person
shoes broke like [ __ ] you want
I mean you you don't look real like you
don't realize we watch basketball
players on TV like and then you be like
okay even the little guys like Chris
Paul remember when I met Chris Paul yeah
Chris Paul Jack yeah yeah six-two right
and that ain't gonna be easy
yeah it was I'm like imagine Andy Mason
or like guys like Shaq I mean when I met
him and was standing at his navel yeah I
met shat on first time when I did like a
it's night show a foul - stand up on it
and 2014 he was the guest on there and I
saw him in the hallway and I that's I
wanted to say what's up without it
that's too big of a person to speak to I
don't want to bother him he has really
giant people stuff to do I got I got a
picture with Amash what I look like a
baby I'm standing next to marriage and
like I look like as mere Marlon Mitchell
spandex and no Marlon is a pretty rotund
guy you don't mind him that your mama's
got a little weight to him he's a little
man little density but we look like
babies standing next to this dude man
and this is after NBA shack where he
loses a little bit of the weight and
starts living healthy
like imagine when he was playing right 7
1 3:45 that's insane we were backstage
once with Blake Griffin and everybody
was saying these super cool take care
everyone
well he purposely does the armor around
the pressure make you look like an egg
you look like a dwarf
every picture he's like yeah cool come
in yeah I did a lot see stuff like that
I think about like Vince Wilfork who
just retired right from the Houston
Texans the defensive tackle I mean
that's will for it right this guy's was
6-3 tipping the scales at about 3:45
yeah like what vaginas can take that
like that's a lot of that's a lot of
train come even if even if the lead
engine is small and still the rest of
the train coming behind that's a lot of
weight like who wants that smoke like I
wouldn't you know that's out the female
that's off the female a combine that
with the fact that he might be ugly we
just got a lot of money so you're gonna
take this you know say hats off to
females I couldn't do it
I have a reliable source that Scottie
Pippen ones ruined somebody's internal
or just Christ you know what to do
Abbott are you looking at it like Judas
well Scottie's kitty but then you you
see in the real life here I yeah man
Scottie ain't skinny don't I'm not
starting no fight with no NBA player now
reach advantage tell her to take
governing a 5-1 healthy 268 reach it oh
yeah at six seven amazing cardiovascular
right i inherent in their retirement no
but a still healthier than you yeah
still healthier like too much of good
stuff I'll get to be going to be fight
[Music]
[Applause]
me
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shun shun in France yeah
shave your face with bevel because this
episode is brought to you by them and
its desired for coarse curly hair and
sensitive skin stepping up your shave
games real simple just get the get bevel
Cobb slash Hannibal there's getb e ve
l.com slash Hannibal and get them good
deals no razor bumps live smooth get the
full shave system and a futuristic
trimmer all of that all of that good
stuff
get to get bevel calm slash Hannibal I
guess save save some money look good
stay trim you mentioned Deon you and
Deon started out around the same time no
actually Dion was BM was on before me I
came in with guys like Marcus combs yeah
me Marcus combs we kind of came in all
around at the same time Frank Townsend
just to name a few
just about 90 I started on comedy 95 9
95 own from the military so I did I did
time in the military that came on when I
was finishing out my reserve obligation
I started doing stand-up and you know D
Island them were a little bit of had a
Dion Corey Holcomb Daniel Williams
actually it was the first person ever
put me on stage so you know I'm always
indebted to him and Tony Schofield was
the second person to ever bring me up on
stage so this goes kind of like my Big
Brother's in the game and always
respecting even to the point where this
day if a promoter calls me to do a show
with them I feel funny about them if
they say well you know Dan is going open
for you I'll be like well now let me
host yeah they didn't go last
like Daniel hoes and let me go like I
just to me it's a respecting right then
I could never see myself yeah you go out
before me that is one of the guys that
put me on yeah a lot of people used to
be like Oh what you scared us not that
I'm scared like lots of [ __ ] that y'all
don't really learn about disrespect it's
like you DJ Tony so like if jazzy jeff
is the last DJ no Tony's a professional
he's not going to go out and burn up all
of the hot [ __ ] yeah because it's nine
o'clock you know at night and nobody's
really as he was being a dick tonight
[ __ ] you okay at all odds but it's just
as like an etiquette thing man and I've
learned that too and just translate
translated even over when I DJ they was
like why do you play this one plays as I
said because your headliners gonna play
all right you know I I lubricated your
vagina he's gonna stamp he's getting
paid to that ever get paid the lubricant
yeah you gotta know you're opening your
opening role the openers roll and it's
an ego thing it's a little bit of
bringing your ego down you know cuz you
want to turn up and be like yeah but you
can still rock the joint now you can
still be adult comic without going over
your time without stepping on everything
that the headline is doing or trying on
some new [ __ ] that's it yeah um what do
you think a the big difference is with
you know if you're your era coming up in
the mid 90s versus you know the new
comedians you see right now ah
well unfortunately the internet social
media is a gift and a curse for new
comics it's a gift for the simple fact
that somebody like DC young fly could
turn a profitable career and using
Instagram to do 15-minute sketches or
whatever and then turn that into an
acting career whatever that's the pros
of it the kinds of it is that everything
is microwave everything's microwave and
nothing is there's no creativity they're
like kind of doing the same thing you
re-edit it you know you get it you get
to sit up to edit it
was perfect was coming out when we did
we had rooms that man listen it's like
listening to a song Tony you know before
it gets to the hook whether this [ __ ] is
hot you got 30 seconds to impress me
when I hear your music your first 30
seconds you yelled yeah you did and cut
this [ __ ] off let's get to it let's go
back we were coming up comedy you went
to Diane quarters room at the click on a
Saturday night you could be ripping like
dismantling the [ __ ] room it's time
they stopped playing juke music up stand
here people laugh but you you you had a
thick skin that should happen to some of
these comments now they have a fit
[ __ ] you audios like no dog you're not
bombing is just something right now
that's a little bit better than you you
don't man and we get it that's that room
and we had different rooms to perform in
and you had to be funny you didn't just
get on because this person knew you yet
I tell people all the time when jokes
and notes was running Mary they used to
think Mary was like very tough I said
boy Mary is so nice now if you
[ __ ] knew the time Nazi we know
the time Nazi y'all know Mary
we knew the time Nazi the time Nazi like
they get mad when she comes standing at
the stage when you going over your time
stand right and right at the stage that
ain't [ __ ] when she was the time Nazi
she used to get on the mic at the DJ
booth get the [ __ ] off the stage
oh sure and then everybody look back now
your [ __ ] yeah you didn't a people
start laughing at you Mary's like get
all my dad named you got out you didn't
work you had the trials you had to
audition to do open mic on Wednesday
night at all jokes aside any and
everybody went up at jokes and notes so
it's just a I think the bars been
lowered a little bit and and I think
sometimes comedy gets watered down
everybody has a room that didn't happen
magnate everybody didn't have the room
certain people had alone Damon had this
room George Willborn had this room
Cory's hocum had these room but these
were all established killers now
guy-girl has been doing comedy for two
weeks got a world and you can't tell
them their day to [ __ ] because they got
a room because they uncle owns a lounge
and this is my room and you know I'm
dope and I'm like you got five minutes
and three and a half for that [ __ ] don't
work but I mean I to their credit
I think as when you're in that brand new
you if you to existing you gotta have a
rule because who else gonna put you up
and [ __ ] but see that and that's another
thing like I feel like I'll give you I
give everybody a shot worked out rooms
are just for that not even explain that
to the crowd when I'm hosting this is an
open mic night you're gonna get some
good you're gonna get some bad now where
you don't want that is is on a weekend
at a comedy club you want everybody that
the bill has to be perfect but this
right here these are these are sample
chefs we creating samples and I tell the
newcomers when they come up if you know
you got a solid joke do that [ __ ] and
get the [ __ ] out of here instead of
trying to fill the time trying to fill
the time I tell you three five minutes
but doesn't mean you have to use it all
right if you don't you know I'm saying
because you know five minutes goes by
quick when you rip it yeah it's the
longest [ __ ] in the world when you throw
out a couple of jokes and they don't
work it's the worst
I had this comment what was that gig at
man this young cat I hear he had asked
for a guest spot on the gig it had been
about six months ago but then I had to
move because of something and then we
rescheduled the gig and I even I forgot
about that guest by then he just
backstage and [ __ ] now like staring
action yeah oh I get it and I was a fine
man you can do you can do five or
whatever and he did like 17 and I had to
open and I said what hey what the [ __ ]
I didn't never
again bro you won't ever and they don't
get it like they're like how can I think
I don't even get how you can do 17 off a
five and I think you should know it's
like no man this is a show like Annie I
couldn't even I was trying to like how
can you I can get maybe doing an eight
eleven and seven five five right but
seventeen over five like where did you
think you were and where's Richard and
where you rip in that hole he was not
written in I was me elevated words yeah
I just like you know I say that all the
time like comics go out I said you're
not hurting me when I did college of
college with a couple of comments they
were all knew I was the like old gone
show everybody that went out I shown the
end they hit ripping whoo everybody's
doing over there time first con was
supposed to do chin he did 15-second
comic was supposed to be 15 he did 25 it
kinda came out after him was supposed to
do like 10 to 15 20 to 25 we got to be
out of the building at 11 I hit the
stage at 1046 who I was supposed to do
45 minutes so say that's promoter was
sick you still had to give me mine and I
was getting a nice little chunk of
change but I said I just told to do this
together I said man 1 all this [ __ ]
y'all did I went out and did one joke to
erase that and get the crowd was with me
so if you think he was going out there
to make me bomb that's not gonna happen
and - not only did you cheat the people
that came to see me you cheated that
promoter cuz he didn't get his money's
worth out of me but guess what I'll be
back he's gonna cut he's gonna bring me
back but I bet you y'all won't be back
and y'all ribs now I'd be a job bank I
said what wasn't worth it
like you got to realize the businesses
about relationships really Bernie Mac
told me that he's like man 80% of this
[ __ ] is relationship
20% is your actual telling music cuz
I see a lot of members that come in here
that I don't think it's funny but they
good people I let them go up I say wow
Bernie for real he's like yeah man said
but at the end of the day if you always
like you said you being a dick who wants
to work with you and that's part of
being a dick if you if you just said
this is my show bro
but go ahead do five and you popped into
seventeen that's blatant disrespect
I don't even respect anything that you
gave me this opportunity it's a theater
show I was like yo man yo are you
seriously come on bro it was uh it was
it was wild reckless when'd you uh meet
birdie for the first time I see him live
the first time I ever met Bernie uh I've
started doing comedy I used to do the
Cotton Club Monday night he originally
used to hosted then he left and Beyond
hosted the d11 and they gave me the job
and he came through saw me do a show so
I want you to come to my spot Milton is
he had a spot called millionaires and
this was well does it was downtown like
nice and like Swank like downtown like
in that air banks little section not a
really nice man and it was he doing
movies at this point oh yeah it is here
at midnight Mac the show HBO okay that's
actually how the the concept for the
midnight night show came from
millionaires and what was crazy if I can
recall and Milton is you either got paid
$25 a drink a drink tab or a copy of
your show those are your three options
yeah here the video a videotape copy of
your show you can get a drink tab which
is $25 or you can get $25 cash so me you
know being a new comic I wanted to copy
of my tape right to get more work from
yeah than I could perform that and you
enough there all you had to do is like
five minutes you went up there and he
used to tell you go up there you do go
first five minutes no more no less
get the [ __ ] off my stage and família
always you to just talk to us he was
cool always approachable man that's what
I love about him like I'm like damn I'm
talking to Bernie Mac
to him use economy right and the
greatest story of Bernie ever for me
David William just have a room called
TNT comedy hood out in Lansing it's not
Dixie kitchen okay and he still does he
do stuff there now
somebody do some comedy that's not a
Dixie kitchen is uh Chili's okay Cory
shout out to Cory Cory Bell she does
Tilly's it used to it's a little bar
restaurant off the channel Sundays I
recommend everybody to go check out this
beautiful spot um we all standing in and
Sunday night at ten T coming hook
because that was the room to be I mean
you're new comment using will get lay
eat good females up there just crazy
like new comics under par so much
booking I got go up yeah I got going no
the opposite lesser but we're all
standing in that talking Damon is
getting the lineup car ready DJ dollar
building one and two doing this thing
Bernie Mac walks in and everybody just
gets quiet and he was like then one go
up working on my set for kings of copy
he was working on this set for King on
the continent and he said I want to go
up first so look was already all struck
that Bernie just walked in the Lansing
but you know a punk Chicago from the
grins no say he move around he shoot at
just guns range all that we are already
all struck that Bernie Mac as well game
but he's like I want to go first animal
when I say he went up on that stage and
the whole [ __ ] you tell that
[ __ ] he was working on that the
milk I could he's all that [ __ ] is gone
I came to the house other day man and
1:30 in the morning
the two-year-old fender [ __ ]
downstairs for milking cook
I'm going up stand he coming down he got
walked past me like I'm a visible I said
where you going
is it to get anything cooking you said
it so fun I want to hear again if it
gives a lot he says I'm an Hancock I
told my baby man is too goddamn late for
some damn cookies and milk man take your
punk ass upstairs and get some rest hot
dogs on [ __ ] that time out [ __ ] I got
top 50 badass here dick here to kill you
they don't kill me I'll kill them I can
see you're reading jetting everything
right now I'm here tongue the same huh
Bernie [ __ ] up though damn kid I can't
get no rest day walk around a house
Three Forks harder them on cut the
finger on my nose hit him breathing all
the counts it badass humming my [ __ ]
rockin all the goddamn time no
psychologist finish lemon mango fifth as
he won't go up stand the two year or her
to your face where the cook is in jail
and he went up and did like 30 up top
boom Funk Flex bomb dismantled joint
what [ __ ] running pulling up ladies
have his baby the baby got the [ __ ] was
crazy and then he goes he goes he goes
again yeah I like that
I think i'ma keep them and we all send
up here like Damon was like Leon you
neck what could you talking about
next to do what clean up is ground zero
he just dismantle disappear but this is
where I kind of felt like an N Bernie
like he look at heat literally at the
pep talk son of the only one you didn't
have to tell type of Corey Corey it was
like [ __ ] I'm ready let's go yeah so dad
was like Ike or you go Corey when Rick
he's likely on your way I'm like I guess
like I mean I'm mind you I'm not aiming
doing comedy that long and I'm sure like
I'm a red look there Sunday night people
loved him like [ __ ] Bernie man and
did Corey Holcomb came by like that two
totally different styles of time
hey where is my little corn ball [ __ ]
fit in like I'm really such a bunny like
man just go up there and do you went up
there and boom hit and then Muhammad
went up boom it was like one of the
coldest nights I've ever been on the
show that wasn't like an arena show that
[ __ ] was amazing man and Bernie was like
that's why I love Chicago we got some
talent out here he said I purposely came
with it
- [ __ ] you show up I wanted y'all to
bomb Oh but Bernie wasn't like he tested
like that he was the big brother he's
the big brother man you know when he got
sick and he passed man it hurt you know
a big piece of Chicago copyleft cuz he
was one of the real ones yeah he's one
of the rules that's that's dope man
yeah sometimes you can get intimidated
when somebody go up and rocket but this
sometimes you just you could just ride
the wave or you could be like [ __ ] that
let's go yeah you could be on some magic
and bird [ __ ] let's go come here I'll
hear you hear you Russell Westbrook
Kevin direction
yeah if sometimes I went out to beat
I've been at the Comedy Cellar
for a while and I'll pop in like I'm
just there to really work on some stuff
but I ain't even you know I'm just kind
of and then somebody going before me and
they'll light it up and have it like she
I was even planning on but you know what
I'm real talking this might see this
might seem crazy and people might
condemn me for this but there are three
comedians that I have my reservations
about going behind cuz they're just to
me they're so [ __ ] phenomenal they
like they just take the energy [ __ ] that
they admit it's hard to match was it one
of them when he when he does his show
and don't [ __ ] around Marla Mitchell
like yeah some of them are kelly stuff
me myself personally if I have any
daughters I'm gonna catch it for a star
and gonna be no slickered people in the
basement having brothers looking like me
coming to dota more hey miss Mitchell so
we're lucky Shane
I'm gonna slip some hormone pills in my
daughter's full-body bayes's so when
they get old and heavy real big like me
muscular they go rocking not only head
no hands don't you talk just like their
daddy dance why muscles bigger than
y'all so to look like if you look so
pretty come on in the car
then why we got big old big legs and
stuff hmm I do just naturally fun right
somebody that walks into a room and you
just thought giggling is the [ __ ] way
he looks and then if he's gone second is
Tony Roberts I would new Tony Robbins is
gonna be a part of all these rappers rap
is [ __ ] today in about really well if I
had another song with Lil Wayne I'm a
kick some I'm a [ __ ] face is he the
only one I'm a lizard I'm a frog I'm a
wizard
[Music]
[Applause]
what kind of machine is this one [ __ ]
tomorrow come I put him together the
next time I took a boat a substance
paste in a bowl of accident he's a
genius though he keep rapping about
nothing and we behind it
[ __ ] and third guy free - summer man my
friends never believed on African I
remember I told my friends it was like a
big shock to them I said dude I'm
Nigerian American where we thought you
like regular black what the [ __ ] is
regular Crayola coming out with colors I
don't know about I said well you call my
parents house my father pick up the
phone you think you talked to the Lion
King I think the god ring please look
here and one still alive who in the hell
is Bobo
Godfrey is on his silly [ __ ] yeah I'm
cool I'm cool win get to going all the
characters it or just doing silly [ __ ]
like I remember one day this dude in an
Instagram post and he said what the [ __ ]
is going on the stuber's they got one
banana on the plate and look you got a
tag that says but not know what that
suggests and my kids will and so on I'm
like damn like and then I tried to
combine I was like this crazy I'd like
gonna be like I say orange and it's like
not funny dad I go [ __ ] you out here how
you let's see if you can eat you have to
today cuz I'm not buying [ __ ] dad
exactly
the guys are gonna be your daddy and
then my wife comes out the back he
almost was yeah they only put Godfrey on
last at the Comedy Cellar I do man
oh he's only the years I've been doing
the Comedy Cellar
you look at the lineup he's never been
in the middle okay when he does the
improv out in Schaumburg
here comes on the radio yes it would
I'll say [ __ ]
I just got enrolled you say he's always
on and just hope my bosses ain't
listening and yet we get him we could
get rid of Leon yeah and Tony Roberts so
much energy where you let but you can't
I can't I can't tell you Tony Roberts
Joe I'm [ __ ] like Mike I know he's
one of the funniest people in the world
but I'm glad tell you better but trust
my word why is that because it's just
this rapidly just it's just energy and
performance this is crazy
yeah like he'll be like just ah he just
did that it's like it's it it's so this
shit's great cuz I saw he did a club in
Phoenix I did the early show he did the
the late shows I stuck around watched
his show I was talking with him oh okay
yeah did you watch the show there with
you yeah yeah I remember being like whoa
look at what he's doing with that chair
he's crazy
yes he's anything like he said
performance ours yeah yeah oh you can't
take like easy he'll be all stared you'd
be like younger slapped so hard at it
yeah and he was like yeah well I told
mobile and then he'll sing a song like
you got the breath of a thousand ass
yeah and then just come up with some
[ __ ] I start singing I'm like it's
[ __ ] amazing
sliding the cross yeah he's stoned in
there [ __ ] already around
he was like performance art yeah so it's
like I don't
and each time I see him it's different
yeah I so I'm just like this
[ __ ] insane bro I can't pop it
like I would never even try I got you I
got me back nah bro yeah I'll take less
money I because that was just his
Energy's a ball he's super saying like
he's Dragon Ball Z like it's like uh he
go to different levels with that [ __ ] I
was trying to ask him where do you try
out material
anyway do it anyway look at it cast its
pillow ah yeah as well I brought a
redeposit got a Waterloo CGI a bit all
right you just like you laughing you
know much you don't realize his love of
his go to those always he's great like I
would love to see him [ __ ] with this oh
I probably have a seizure laughing yeah
I probably wouldn't even use it anymore
it's like him and Godfrey that they got
that same type of like energy
yeah but then guys we add the African
stuff penguin so it's just those are two
people and like I say Marlon is just
like when Marlins not giving thanks to
God yeah cuz he annoys me I love Marley
we got man this is beautiful God got us
all here
yeah but when lollie like gets into it
[ __ ] I wanna be funniest dudes I've ever
seen in my life
yeah man shut out the Marlin Charlie
check out Francis cocktail lounge yes
sir every Monday just niching them doing
a comedy up there
I don't 79 for nine 75th 75th seven
friends right our Airlines on 75th
Street yeah in the shot goes into Yemen
when you start DJing oh I've been DJing
now this will be year number seven
you're number seven F and actually what
was crazy about it
I was just doing it for fun because I
just always watch DJ dollar bill mm-hmm
and the club in the comedy club and I
used to do this thing with of Peter
Piper
we're on DMC I used to be like dooba
dooba dooba dooba dooba dooba dooba
dooba dooba DP DP DQ
there it is be here and then I was gone
crazy [ __ ] old friend of other things
like that out of here and I just thought
that was so amazing and I thought DJ's
and comics are wanting the same in this
aspect and stop me coming from you is
just you in the booth it's just you on
the stage you'll open it how you get the
people in when you first start your
setup
you play it you get the dance well
Crockett you got everybody laughing tell
the wrong joke lose the crowd play a
wrong song they disperse off the
dancefloor and sometimes it's hard to
get them back yeah well sometimes you
can come back when you rip it and kill
it standing over when you ripping and
killing [ __ ] [ __ ] look up it's
three o'clock the club's closing they
like oh no [ __ ] that man you did your
thing
so they're parallel in the fact that
they master ceremonies we control crowds
but of course I think the biggest
difference though is that a lot of times
the promoters of a club will purposely
asked you to play songs that will
disperse the crowd so [ __ ] go
yes we'll drink but I play a song
that'll dead this crowd right now
because [ __ ] aren't buying
drink right now
but even with that being said when you
that bad [ __ ] yeah man good mood
get the [ __ ] like rest in peace Timbuktu
I've seen promoters come to come and be
like man kind of slow it down
ya know it's a killer that 210 days be
like do you want my father to be back in
this [ __ ] next week now leave me the
[ __ ] alone
yeah and all you just do the I can't
hear you okay
yeah I keep going well I do that that's
my man yeah yeah yeah yeah I'd be Jay
sometimes and it was just this girl I
did this little good hearted to open to
myself while I was on the mic let's play
all the songs with flutes so I play like
that a half gone I went I closed with
the mask off it was something from
Playboy cardi and it was at Chris Brown
Gucci Mane
tone it down they got it and then that
plague mask off
and then this girl comes up into my
right hears this song is so this song is
so March but is in stop I need you give
her that I just just that I just kept
looking at the laptop to look over at it
kept on saying it
she said that's it about five times
and then just walked off you know my
buddy system back and I just watch him
do things that he just [ __ ] it on the
hood like the music not even that laughs
he's like ha ha ha you know my father's
been doing to me lately when I do that I
cuz I do that move all the time this is
what they do they pull it up on the note
do it like yeah [ __ ] so that is
the most annoying [ __ ] I just have my
cousin my cousin day we're gonna not I
just have them stand at the DJ exactly
like what do you want he be like I want
the ass alright what do you want I
didn't know like what guys to be like
man yo I want to ask him could he play
he say so let me get this straight
you're a man and you're gonna act
another man and play something I
actually wanna stop and grade this [ __ ]
out of ladylike I and the females he'd
be like you know feel say some credible
[ __ ] to their baby when I want my friend
one here yo so what's what's goin on
y'all messing with the DJ and security
happen yeah cuz that's how the [ __ ] gets
played honey my oh my god asses oh but I
don't get bothered it's not ass I don't
get by the way works
yeah but um watching dollar bill all the
time and dollar bill was like I would be
okay with my house when there's all a
requisition that I had it she's like
dude why don't you DJ I was like I'm not
a DJ bro I just love music and being in
the military help because when I went
abroad I met more people and I know cuz
living in the Midwest man we didn't
really have a style when it came to
hip-hop you know if you kind of
understand what I'm saying you know the
east coast yet mobb deep get wu-tang you
had you had a sound
florida-based music you know you had
radio and Joe Cool 2 Live Crew you know
poison clan didn't even when you win the
Texas Scarface you know you had ghetto
boys then of course the West Coast
g-funk and all that stuff in the Midwest
we were kind of like in the 90s we were
floating we didn't really have we are
like gangster [ __ ] and we had like Jay
Lester
but we now mind you once again that's
later we talking early early 90 turns
over there oh we didn't we did what are
you high he's 11 not it barely that's
like a hen I was biting like Dazs
effects god I hope they can figure it
out stuff like I'm ripping it like so
ligament you feel like oh [ __ ] my it's
ridiculous I just like need every time
and can I borrow a dollar album even
with that like you still talking it
still had it was Midwest but it had New
York appeal exactly okay so I was until
late 90s 2000 the twisters crucial
conflict you know I listened to da smart
not little guys but they weren't
nationally known artists very smart to
me to this day shout-out to Darius
market the other seaters may one of the
coldest gangsta songs ever in the
history of Chicago revenues is called
walk with me where he takes you on oh
that gives you every gang from the top
to the bottom I didn't know that all
that I was I didn't know who that's
that's his name but I definitely smiling
walk with me
yes wonder if you came to Chicago and
didn't know [ __ ] about our gangs that's
101 you listen to that song and you'd be
like okay I'm not gonna go here and if I
get shot on the west side don't let them
take me to Loretta Hospital cuz I'm
gonna die cuz the opposite that got
about that short heard and we're gonna
close it out on that there so Mickey
Halsted and all them guys you know they
came a little bit later so we didn't
have an identity in Chicago until you
know the Commons in the Kanye's started
coming along what you could you know
really see Chicago hip hop so when I
went abroad and just started listening
to everybody's music cuz you know I was
rooting mob you know big nice that's all
of rocked him the god I'm just this all
I do gangsta you know but then when I
went and I'm like damn poison clan home
team oh wow you and C's oh wow Houston
oh wow the west coast got hip-hop my
father
our griffix / I feel the saucy Nomad mr.
EE - mr. Bob de Molina I'm like oh wow
[Music]
mr. da ballina mr. Bob EE - mr. Bob EE
the was too quick you really make me
sick with your puzzling behavior do you
wanna make it different in army just say
because no when I thought West Coast all
I thought was gangbangers you know Snoop
Dogg and all that so he was like now you
need the mixed up you need to DJ and I
was like I said let me teach you he
broke out the twelves I used to go over
his house in Indiana when he lived in
hammy and I learned on 12 no Serato
nuttin learning straight records you
know and then uh I thought done he said
man I want you to come over here every
day and just learn how to be juggle I
said dollar bill we were cool that
sounded real gay that sounded like
Nicole come over and be like what
exactly do you mean by beat I'm not like
that but that's very fortunate that you
got to learn off of vinyl okay I feel
like a lot of these kids are missing out
controlling on yeah it's just when you
learn on vinyl you have a different way
different appreciation of the music
itself and just the art of turntable
landmines you too being in Chicago I
come from house music see when I was a
teenager we went to house parties a lot
it was no one know hip-hop parties like
that we were going to house parties even
a lot of your DJ's today like a guy like
v-dub right who you hear v-dub mixtape
bully you know you get your best song
but b-doubles
one of the dopest house DJs in Chicago
Farris Thomas same way they just
reinvented themselves you know Terry
hunter all that these guys were house
DJ's so with that background and
learning how to blend and of course step
it that's another thing you know the
step of sex you you learn how to blend
music so once I got that down I just
kept working and I started by my own
equipment and I reached out to a lot of
DJ's who I respected and thought was
dope and some of them you know
looked at me like get the [ __ ] outta
here you are you trying to capitalize on
what we do be a quote-unquote celebrity
DJ well when that never was my goal
I never wanted like I didn't never want
somebody like Tony's and look at me like
oh he's a celebrity digit I want
something like Tony be like Joe that
[ __ ]
rocked that set you know I'm say or he
inspired me to go pull some records I'm
not crazy that ain't been using in a
while and I think that was one of my
advantages I didn't come up
DJing from laptops yeah because now I
don't write for passage to that's carry
around yeah and get your arms you ball
and tear rotator cuff to look like I
just like just take unload your car with
Craig's records like to rock a party and
your friends and get friends with you
and all that yes but but I will say this
though just like I don't want to be the
old man on the line when it comes to
comedy and I can't be mad at comedians
that use Instagram and Facebook as a
platform because I think high high Davis
is amazing yeah it's gonna be a breeze
like that [ __ ] is funny but that's
because you can do that I can't be mad
at technology you need because you know
it does save you a lot of work when you
can get 50,000 songs right there that's
just you can bring your whole life
traveling yeah absolutely so even with
the controllers it's all that's a more
about convenience now yeah when you got
people that's sinking and and cheating
and doing all that but they don't
respect the craft anyway and it's going
to come out and let's be honest we got
to blame the audience sometimes even
with comedy Hannibal you can relate to
this you'll get somebody like Tony woods
who's brilliant writer and write write
something so crazy and over-the-top but
the audience is so used to you yeah make
a female stuck get so much as nosebleed
hey it's microwave and we want those we
want the quick last we don't want to sit
and listen to your story and wait for
the punchline at the end we want it now
and like with DJ and when I go to a club
if you sit and listen right do you just
don't have to blend it up do nothing all
our blender all
crowd one is their favorite song play
that's all they want and the end to the
fact that they don't care that if you
were just on and you played mask off
both a yellow and bad and boozy and I
come back on and I play both yellow mask
off bad and we don't give a [ __ ] I
thought you could straight you get like
legit be killing just happens to be all
done killing the dancefloor
destroying everybody dancing my [ __ ]
still got a request
yeah why yeah do you have a request your
[ __ ] yourself yeah by the way from my
boat like why aren't you dancing with
death I'll just go it's a model fest
everybody wants to pose and then new
clothes that Balenciaga Hermes right and
everybody wants to stand and chill and
this is why I like I'm so glad now like
I try to create lands with parties like
for my birthday I did an indoor beach
party but it was all 90s teen you know
I'm saying so I said so if you're coming
here to hear the trap you're gonna be
upset right
cuz we're not playing the [ __ ] we're
gonna have a good time playing music
from 1990s all the way into mid 2000s
and we'll have a good time it's like and
I feel like a DJ's job personally is to
keep music alive I feel like your job is
to keep hot [ __ ] alive and I just let it
get lost
I blame I blamed partially actually I
blame a lot of like the Spotify
streaming generation because it's
everything so instant and then they give
you the what's hot now you know you like
this and it's like it's a different yeah
right so like back in the days when when
I first started like I dug you know tons
an like I'd have the go places find
shocking wax you over here I yeah
exactly you know like gramophone I had
to I had to dig yeah like now I don't
think it's just right there a touch
Google and then they tell you oh you
like playboy guarding this guy out you
just like there it's instant I've no to
you two doing out at that like I one day
I was DJing with this guy and I was just
looking at all his equipment I was like
you know this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] trash like you've been dropping
in or whatever and I was like yo bro
will you get your music from because I'm
listening to him playing and dish it
sounds honorable oh man I'll pull
everything of YouTube that's crazy you
know you're not in the record pool
you're not in like you know I mean the
$20 that you spend on that loud you can
take that $20 a month I have access to
thousands of songs here I said I said
the lot of the DJ's don't even care
about the crap is just like I want to
get into the club free excuse my French
[ __ ] a few [ __ ] off this cuz we all
know the DJ gets tail and that's it I
want to live like that like and then
then you're disrespecting the game
that's another thing too I got into a
lot of promoters because I knew my worst
you know saying Amy oh yeah we got this
party once you do downtown we charge 50
to get in but we want you you know can
you spend from 9:00 to 12:00 you'll be
the first DJ for $150 it's good exposure
no [ __ ] my kids can't eat
exposure what I plan is that is that
general they'll get a folder
I still get exposure offers oh it's
great exposure thing but you know my
tone I'm not even mad at that man
depending on what it is hey man Barack
Obama's having to swing this body you
need somebody to keep the mood right
ain't really no money okay
I mean well I swing the party's gonna be
a it's convicted upset you know let
anybody at that time you know that
shorty might walk through there [ __ ]
shout out to my man I'm ban on there and
I know and some other people that they
throw swinger parties also they go to
Jesus right you know said so I'm gonna
charge the rock I got a feel but like no
[ __ ] Friday night that y'all do
with somebody's probably gonna get shot
afterwards in the parking lot no I can't
do that
you gotta pay me at least you know I'm
said if it's 300 people in here y'all
charging $20 at all you mean to tell me
I can't get a dollar off every year a
dollar and that's like work right but
but DJ but the rates in Chicago are
[ __ ] up and there but cuz the younger
guys just want to be the
wanted to say that I DJ this part no
they don't they don't know that you are
the part you can literally but now was
so [ __ ] up about that is the promoter
goes like oh you're not gonna play will
let me get out my little exactly well
you know what there's two generations of
these uh these DJ's right now you got
the guys that have the Spotify and you
can just stream whatever and just kind
of play do whatever it's at their
fingertips and then you got like the
nerdy vinyl collector like a name
calling Randall's right but they just
slammed I like but they're special
because they play vinyl but they don't
know they don't know blend no no
creative no creative transitions SS play
this song playing for PBRs y'all like
that yeah
the play for Peter not even that rock
this one yes like that's the nerd just a
nerdy link the eclectic muffler yeah
like playing for PBR I hear the crackle
yeah yeah yeah the audiophile nerd
record collects so I mean you know I
just try to be respectful to crap that
I'm in and I look at it as a crap I look
at it as you know something that if
you've been doing it for thirty
something years I don't automatically
assume that I could come in and bless it
I worked hard like I practiced for at
least two two and a half years before I
even went outside
Wow with it and when I went outside I
did a family barbecue yeah and you know
my father kept it one honey is like yeah
stick to the commies I was like why I
can't play no Motown you know yeah I
couldn't take him seriously cuz going
you ain't played an old dress song about
[ __ ] you old man yeah yeah oxygen tank
up the middle
yeah yeah Yemen glad to have you on the
show Leo I know you got to get out of
here man oh well I'm glad to be here man
listen
all right Hannah I wanna tell you doc
proud of you man thank you for watch
their journey from from first time ever
met your southern Illinois where my man
rje we was down there do a show yeah -
the fact that you doing what you're
doing now and you still come home and
[ __ ] with the land
yeah you know like you Dion you guys
y'all still come on I live out here I
know I guess the night before today
because you keep your make yourself
scarce yeah man yeah la oh come back as
like no y'all just don't see him ride a
nice yeah you don't care I did the
packet y'all coming you guys like you
guys like Deon Cole like Deon comes home
and is on 70 [ __ ] fifth yeah you know
I'm saying so that that's that special
man be right all you guys I'm just proud
of you and then I know that uh my
self-esteem doesn't go down as much as
you used to anymore when people come and
be like why you ain't it la with animal
in them just sit on the radio for
[ __ ] 15 years of the third-largest
naked right I'm okay quiet man I please
so here be a video game you over
goldfish put a Nintendo 64
Jojo I playing a game in the sea where
they go to the ball but uh Hannibal cut
my head man you ain't gonna shoot me huh
appreciate y'all man
make sure y'all follow me at Leon Rogers
on Instagram Twitter Facebook is my name
don't put no D in my last name I don't
do the Diaz ro ger [ __ ] that's like
the guy that just come in and change
what is the shoes girl ever thought that
was weird like black man do that you
committed a crime that he did this [ __ ]
it was normal yeah well if you change
you who [ __ ] you just can't all right
but you're putting money your right foot
and off with me through the city of
Chartres where the folks speech have you
heard and if any crime sociologist be
telling me to fini dies my mother's
murder the gang banging the term million
every 30 hours they found another body
was buzzing him and ain't no burden
insisted you think [ __ ] it ain't no
love in it that we will call with the
South I would you need to be teased the
black doll don't cause I don't leave me
your tool - so when you in a certain
area you will know what that comprise
the list of the folks who will open the
door of the voir dire to pick if they
know each other supporting a mistake so
mingle but just a few goodness knows you
got bees on a three finger recalls it
allowability turn-based if fifties we
running to vote believe nations up in
the trailer they'd have but they paint
baby
walk with me
if you're bugging me to know exactly who
the door gets Adam and Mia polish you're
happy about me coming identify your body
[Music]
in the industry with master key off with
me into the city for the folks over to
my lord
you call me if we can really know when
you will mow down when [ __ ] know of
the time at that age they can't go you
got it bro the six trade like those one
at every I an A+ grade was a park in
Tarrytown remember the fourth and Devils
have to tear it down but 87 m3 damn
[ __ ] defined or committed to they live
in and all will adjust the cowboy
secondly sad who's Jesus bikinis the
biddies our mother packed out of our
cities and every Marilyn how to be well
to say
mr. Breen into the car agency I could
put the marbles in the Kurds only
thought did not let me really encompass
Nami chicken skin the complicated role
then is the lip inhales body drop it all
[Music]
go to me walk with me with me to take a
trip to the width ah what people in they
appear telling me is the best time for
me to say it's the fresh shot before my
conviction my consider it is to tell
lies and maybe one [ __ ] is nothing
over 2000 beliefs a is not aware that
subscribe and every nominee can wear
after he go to Mount Sinai Hospital
prepared
let me tell you where the booth will
like anti-wedding to keep people at that
you ll then to cut it down
we even got new breed oh stop that if I
need to fill it the show
bunnelby take the Cosmo you opening on
the 10th oh let me know I love the what
let's go see the plane by slot on the
Avenue I know they are the crazy if I
have a dog then they forgot about the
magazine I was over or watching out
homie you three bulls are unknown like
Chicago Avenue now at the black line of
assertion is ball you can come too many
few owners because the travel advice
those will be waiting on you on
California the apple of our brothers
have your business if you laughing Lucas
and of the point of us waiting after 18
impose that the desire is khalipa you
can't rape and talk to Pete or you could
be on the stage by [ __ ] and walk with
me numbers come in
oh please little pain to infinity and in
the page mystery to the tonic with an
old mate with the competing with me
[Music]